le monde fonctionnent d'une certaine
manière jusqu'au jour où une idée
brillante vient tout révolutionner
imaginez pouvoir faire des analyses de
sang sans sortir de chez vous et
imaginez conduit pas besoin de tout un
peuple mais d'une simple couteau
j'ai décidé d'arrêter mes études cette
machine ne fassent changer le monde les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui sont dans l'action
il n'hésite pas à remettre en question
les anciennes méthodes
ils veulent changer les choses tout de
suite
ensemble nous allons rendre les soins
accessibles à tous les malades 17 a
suivi je comprends pas comment vous
pouvez assurer le travail d'un ingénieur
chimiste avec un diplôme de licence
cette technologie sera fret que dans dix
ans votre idée est impossible mais il
continue en trombe sentiments ici c'est
le ne le fait pas il n'y a pas de
simples c'est iota mais
si c'est ce que tu veux il faut que tu
t'y consacre à fond jusqu'où tu es prête
à aller pour réussir tu peux pas leur
donner la moindre raison et tout et tout
c'est encore très loin de marché
qu'est-ce qu'on va montrer à la limite
on va leur expliquer qu'on n'a pas de
prototypes qui fonctionnait
on est d'accord
notre deuxième levée de fonds nous a
rapporté 165 milliards
je sais ce que tu as fait la
démonstration
c'était une première étape très pro d2
tu ne le dis à personne donc je suis là
pour te protéger c'est une étape une
première étape très prometteuse ce n'est
pas que mon travail c'est mon identité
quiconque tout de mon entreprise
d'autres deux mois
dirige une boîte qui vaut comme yard
son image est basé sur du vent
absolument là
on n'a pas vu un seul contrat je vous
assure qu'elle vous manque
dépassé par la situation
tu vas tout perdre non non ça va bien
tout va trouver
vous ne comprenez rien de business vous
ne comprenez rien à la charge
société mettait des vies en danger
c'est votre rêve c'est votre histoire
les gens croiront en votre et
technologies
[Musique]
parce qu'ils croient rouen vous